alors où la préservation de la planète
devient l'enjeu essentiel de notre
société
les nuits sont lumière contribuer à
sensibiliser à la question de la
pollution lumineuse et à ses effets
négatifs
le département participe au nuit sans
lumière de manière forte puisque depuis
le 5 et ce jusqu'au 24 avril 13 sites de
la collectivité seront plongés dans le
noir
le département participe activement en
éteignant 13 établissements donc du
département nous allons avoir donc la
villa du département l'hôtel du
département le musée léon dierx le
jardin de l'état les archives
départementales et il y en a 13 et c'est
vrai que c'est très symbolique pour
éteindre les lumières mais également
sensibiliser les agents de la
collectivité
c'est vrai que nous essayons aussi de
sensibiliser tous nos agents de la
collectivité pour que chacun fasse un
geste citoyen nous avons passé des notes
de service et puis il ya aussi le bouche
à oreille qui fonctionne très bien et je
pense que comme nous sommes des
personnes responsables
donc tout le monde ferait un geste pour
les nuits sont lumière 2016 outre d'être
un facteur de pollution les lumières
aveugle les jeunes pétrels qui percute
violemment les poteaux lumineux et
terminent leur envol au sol
ces oiseaux blissy constituent des
proies faciles pour les chiens et les
rats les nuls sont en lumière ont pour
objectif de protéger les pétrels qui
sont des oiseaux endémiques de la
réunion et en particulier de protéger
les jeunes pétrels qui sur la période du
5 avril au 24 avril font leur premier
envol
donc ils partent du centre de lille pour
rejoindre la mer et ils sont
malheureusement attiré par les
éclairages publics qui les attire qu'il
disait louis et c'est jeunes pétrels
viennent s'échouer sur sur terre ils ne
sont pas en capacité de s'envoler et à
terre ils sont souvent victimes donc de
chiens ou de chats qui les attaquent
donc l'objectif c'est vraiment permettre
à ces jeunes pétrels de pouvoir réaliser
leur premier envol il de pouvoir
continuer à poursuivre leur vie
au sein de la terre réunionnaise très
symbolique parce que c'est aussi d'un
événement national
et c'est vrai que le pétrel de barau qui
est un oiseau endémique de la réunion
le département qui oeuvre aussi dans le
domaine de développement durable et de
l'environnement se doit de participer à
cet événement la seor la société
d'études ornithologiques de la réunion
qui participent activement au sauvetage
des pétrels récupère soigner au lèche
des centaines d'oiseaux sauver les
pétrels et réduire le gaspillage des
éclairages publics autant de réseaux
pour chacun de faire aussi un geste
citoyen en éteignant ses propres
lumières en matière d'environnement
chaque petit geste compte
ans
oh